Let's look at the computation pipeline for a Video Analytics application. Let's
say I'm interested in detecting and tracking some anomalous
event. So I have cameras, which captures the images from a particular
environment. And you're detecting for something specific.
Maybe you're looking for [INAUDIBLE] in every camera frame, and once
you detect, it shows face then you say
it what? This guy is a suspicious individual, let's
track him as he moves around. So, the
tracking is taking a particular object of interest for
the domain and asking the question What is
happening to that object as time moves on. And
in the process of tracking, you are recognizing who
that person is. If there are multiple people in
a particular alignment, your recognizing the specific
individual that you may be interested in.
And if that individual is recognized, then
perhaps you want to raise an alarm. So, this
is just a simple pipeline of tasks to illustrate what a domain expert may be
doing in a video analytics application. So such a domain expert is an expert in
writing detection algorithms, tracking algorithms, and. Recognition
algorithms so that they can process the video stream in
real time to generate alarms. So the objective in Situation
Awareness applications is to process these streams of data
for high level inference. In other words, we're not watching a
YouTube video, but we're using the sensor
streams to derive high level inferences to
what is happening in the enlighnment. And that's what is the nature of Situation
Awareness applications. As I mentioned Video Analytics
is in the purview of a domain
expert like a vision researcher or a
developer, who knows how to write sophisticated
detection, tracking, and recognition algorithms. But how
do we scale that up to thousands of
cameras? If an object is moving from one
camera to another, these are the kinds of
things that the domain expert. For Situation
Awareness may have to worry about, this is
where systems can come in with programming models
that alleviate the pain points of a domain
expert developing Situation Awareness applications. Persistent temporal
streams, which is the focal point of
this particular lesson. Is just one exemplar
of a distributed programming system for catering
to the needs of situation awareness applications. Such as, what I described
to you, just now. I want to stress the fact that PTS is just an exemplar,
not the last word. But it is good to look at one concrete example of
a distributive programming system that can help reduce
the pain points in developing Situational Awareness Applications.